and that has been doing it for over two
years for the last three weeks he has
defended his honor of being a regular
here it is an absolute incredible feat
this week we're giving him the week off
of Defending his spot to see as an
experiment if he is literally uh uh
lazier when not being challenged so
we're gonna see if he still does as good
as he has the last three sets and if he
doesn't do his good he's gonna challenge
for his regular spot next week it's all
pro wrestling [__] I think you guys get
it right
ladies and gentlemen here with a brand
new minute the one and only Rolex
swearing hunts Kim
thank you
[Music]
I hope the orcas accept these five human
sacrifices
as a peace offering
and this bloody war between our species
I'm actually gonna start my own
submersible tour of the wreckage of this
submersible tour of
wreckage of the Titanic
I like how Ocean Gate was like Hey you
know how they're all making subs good
how about we make ours shitty
that'll disrupt the space
these [__] billionaires took an Uber
to the Titanic
these [__] Rich bastards would rather
get crushed by the ocean and give us
Health Care
rich people are stupid entertain went to
Romania to be a douchebag rapist
that's right douchebag rapists are
created
that's like moving to Japan to take
upskirt photos
that's like a European moving to America
to do a mass shooting
[Applause]
joke
now let me ask you this did you know you
did weren't gonna be challenged this
week I didn't I had no idea you thought
you were gonna be challenged yes that's
why I tried yeah
exactly what do you think would have
happened do you think you're set
honestly Hans do you think your set
would have been as good if I would have
told you a week ago after the show next
week you're not you don't have to
challenge you're not going to get
challenged for your spot no right it
wouldn't have been as good yeah it's so
honest it's incredible you can't lie he
has a lot of problems but he's super
honest yeah I really hate the
competition I bet you do
it's kind of inhumane I feel like I'm
being exploited
I keep having another comedian come out
into a minute and if he and if and if
they have a better minute than Hans the
audience decides and if the other person
wins they are the new regular and you've
crushed them every time three for three
baby that's right
[Applause]
I love that he can't lie he's like an
Asian George Washington he's like George
takai yeah
oh my I'm not gay
I love it Hans what's been going on this
week with you in your personal life tell
us all about it I've I found out my
girlfriend has Tourette's
how did you find out because she said I
love you
she said my dick was big uh
she uh she told me and then I realized
like whenever we get into a fight and
afterwards she starts like spazzing out
it's kind of cute what do you mean
exactly give us an example of exactly
what happens she'll be honest God you
always come back too late
[Laughter]
comedian's girlfriend
she's like
[Music]
what hold on what
what is that she's just on her computer
going
[Music]
okay that's not a sound that has
anything to do with this Jesus [__]
Christ
what do you what are you what are you
what are you saying she just makes that
noise yeah and you think that's
Tourette's yeah did you talk with her
about it no
I just see what she's looking at when
she's making that noise on the computer
I think it was porn could be yeah I
think she was coming yeah and you've
never heard that sound before
oh
so you're saying this happens after you
get into arguments with her yeah when
she's stressed out she makes that noise
yeah it's kind of hot
I don't know that sounds weird I've
never heard of anything like this anger
activated Tourette's is that a thing
yeah is that a thing with people with
Tourette's I guess so I don't know
anyone with Tourette's out there
yeah really you really have Tourette's
does it help okay
when you get angry does it set it off
yeah it does story checks out really I
want to see
quite hard I'm gonna move you like your
front row seat I'm gonna move you to the
back of the room right now you piece of
[__] oh [__] there it is whoa oh my God
can you record your girlfriend talking
like this and we can put it in this
episode before it gets released I'll do
that yeah yeah start a good argument
with her for no reason and then recorder
all right Hans you think I should have
you challenge for your spot next week no
okay so here's what we're gonna do let's
just treat it like you're being
challenged and the first time that you
have a set in which I find you being
lazy kind of like you were in this weird
Coke spring that you had this Cokey
spring that you went through then I have
a long list because once word got out
three weeks in a row people started I
mean there's a lot of people that are
like I want to challenge Hans for the
Regular Show that's kind of insulting
well I mean you're bodying all of them
so far so congratulations Hans what
happened to those guys who challenged
them and fail
not really they should be punished yeah
no they are they I mean trust me Uncle
laser is going this what happened last
what happened last week is going to
haunt Uncle laser forever there was
literally it was one of those ones where
it went how many of you have Uncle laser
winning this it was I don't know why red
band did that anymore comedic decision
he makes makes no sense but there wasn't
a there was a clap and it was way far
out there and it wasn't right after I
said it but um
good job Red Band just keep smoking that
cigarette buddy
um
Hans I love it you know what's going on
we're pushing you to your absolute
limits we want you to continue to be
great and grow right in front of our
very eyes thank you Tony thank you so
much Hans Kim hey the show started
[Music]
[Applause]
bomb all right your first bucket pull of
the night ladies